welcome everybody seeing that it is um
903 I am going to open the subcommittee
work session on House Bill 1111 referred
for interim study and uh with that I am
going to speak to my fellow subcommittee
members we have a guest who is a member
of the ENA representative Davis who is
here to um
absolutely contribute in any way but as
far as a voting
um Mr Davis doesn't have a vote on the
subcommittee but welcome again and uh
with that I'd like to just let folks
take a minute to look at the proposed
um
subcommittee report that we are looking
at and obviously we as a a subcommittee
with the work session will present a
um recommendation to the full full
Committee of the house environment and
Agriculture and so we are just going to
go through this for a minute it'll be
very informal and we'll make any changes
and suggestions uh cooperatively
together and then hopefully we'll get to
a place since we do have a quorum
established where we can make a
recommendation out
so with that I'll just give us a few
um sure representative Bixby did you
wanna
representative contract uh
representative Bixby um this work
session is either to recommend this for
future legislation or not recommend is
is the choice here
um it's it's different than a study
so to answer the question yes and we can
certainly go through them today too if
there are typographical or minor changes
that you would like to suggest uh happy
to do that and um we can if there are
small sort of scriveners type things
sorry you'll note that the footnotes uh
you each have an electronic draft uh as
well the footnote you can click on and
they will take you directly to that site
representative homela yes thank you uh
the question I I did have so this is
this document is is intended to capture
maybe our discussion on this okay
because right now it's reads like a an
informational document on the topic
that's correct and you'll add to that
that's correct because we haven't made a
recommendation yet so I didn't I left
that sort of bolded area open because we
haven't had that discussion yet today to
make a recommendation forward thank you
okay
we have General representative Stapleton
yeah thank you
um looking at the original Bill and um
its focus is on establishing a
commission to study
extended producer responsibility so
um we're here today to
focus on that and move along on that but
maybe
Rectify some of the language if there's
a problem and any extent on that that's
a great question um so we heard various
levels of testimony last week and there
were different stakeholders just to
review for those of us who weren't sorry
no go ahead
um those of us who were not here who
submitted uh remarks regarding issues
that are still currently for
consideration among various stakeholders
whether it was Municipal associations or
the Department of Environmental Services
itself had some comments that they made
regarding
um sort of the general overall sentiment
of extended producer responsibility so
yes the only two outcomes for this
subcommittee can be to recommend it for
future legislation or not and that could
be in various
um forms there was a discussion last
week on whether or not sub uh a
committee or a commission would be the
most prudent method forward so we could
have that discussion uh for
recommendation to the Full House Ena
committee or something else
representative Bixby yeah I just wanted
to sort of sort of do a sort of
parliamentary clarification so uh the
the bill as it came to us this current
term is essentially not it is no longer
active because because it's in what
interim study is it makes the bill
inactive but it the question is whether
the I some of the ideas from the bill
should be going forward so what our
recommendation would be focused on is
what should future legislation look like
as opposed to should be we be doing
anything with that that previous bill as
does that clarify okay great so so with
that this is really just the background
knowledge of kind of what we're looking
at overall and where we were and and
like I said uh the last hearing we did
hear from municipalities who were
sharing with us that tipping fees are
still
um increasing I think it was generally
72 dollars a ton to an increase around a
hundred and twelve dollars
so uh Wasteland is growing 72.10 20 21
82 a ton
uh in 2022 and that just keeps on a
hundred dollars a ton in 2025. that was
the anticipated sort of increase in uh
tipping fees
um and then uh Des did also comment
about and it is also cited sort of in
the draft report that they have a desire
to see extended producer responsibility
to be a component to how they are
addressing the waste streams within
their Solid Waste plan and that was a
strategy for legislative action 1.9
where it reads explore legislation
including extended producer
responsibility epr programs that would
require product Brands and manufacturers
to enhance the recyclability of their
products and packaging and minimize the
use of necessary materials in single
Des also said that they had just
produced their report they came out on
September 30th so uh something to look
at
um so
I have just for your reference
Representatives sent that along and it
is also a footnote attachment in this
report electronically which you also
have a copy of the draft the working
draft
representative thank you um in the test
in testimony we heard uh it seemed like
the focus of the testimony in the
advocacy of the people who testified was
to do a commission
so that is not necessarily what our
recommendations are legislatively moving
forward that was whether we are through
legislation authorizing a a commission
is that correct as opposed to any other
type of extended producer legislation
if I'm understanding your
question okay
um the conversation was around both the
commission and the committee as
potential options in the future uh to
representative bixby's Point HB 1111 was
the vehicle for which uh the concept of
extended producer responsibility now
sits before us as a subcommittee so now
we are looking through all of the things
that we heard last week as well as sort
of looking at this draft report and
making a decision about what we feel
um
to send essentially a recommendation to
the Future legislature
to look at what would happen next and
what we feel the sentiment is of the
environment and agriculture committee
thank you madam chair I just wanted for
clarification just because I'm going to
be uh signing this document but it says
that this bill and what we're working on
is establishing a commission to study
extended producer responsibility and
basically the motion in my mind is
either we're going to recommend the
commission or we're not
um and other
so I mean we can put down in our
comments that there should be future
legislation but what this committee is
supposed to be working on and is my
understanding is whether we're going to
suggest a commission
uh according to this all right Bill
title
you sure can thank you rep Comfort
okay this still seems to be ambiguous to
me and I
um is there a way we well
um
Christine Miss Grant Miss Grant uh is
there
um do you happen to know about the
Parliamentary distinction in
distinctions here in terms of
uh when the what a vote for recommend
for future legislation or not recommend
for future legislation would imply about
whether it is
recommending the exact same bill or if
it's recommending uh you know the the
confirm my belief and let you know but
and it's technically you don't want this
repetition but if you want
me no that would be that would be
fantastic in this Grant and uh in that
if that is possible then for us to make
recommendation and you can let us know
today uh while we're meeting
okay that's fantastic great thank you
very much
so but with that I would say that we
should still kind of go forward and work
on and think about what we would like um
as far as the content that's already
here currently if folks are happy with
the background knowledge
and what is existing here currently we
can look at that piece
uh Madam chair
um so I understand that you want to look
at this piece here which is very well
done by the way so thank you
um but it also the the bill itself that
we are have been tasked to look at is
very very specific also and what its
so um and when we had looked at it we
did discuss last week sort of the
presiding members the membership of the
commission that would be there uh
representative Stapleton do you have a
copy of the
um Bill itself as it was sent over yes
great okay and so we did discuss uh with
representative partial a little bit
about
um producer stakeholders and where that
may
where they may fit into this as they
were not a named member but they uh
there was testimony last meeting that
those folks may still be called upon
should uh the commission as the bill is
written
desire to have them testify before their
Commission
and obviously the content of the um
the one thing that does make me wonder a
little bit is the the date for the
legislation for September of 2022
has passed so the date is no longer
accurate as the bill sits so that's why
um representative Bixby so uh typically
uh in the
the reporting date the the those the
dates are are considered are not
considered binding when you're doing if
you're recommending future legislation
the dates don't carry along with it uh
because uh it's it wouldn't be practical
right
so representative Pamela are we at the
point where we can discuss this could
like deliberate right we can I can is
this the appropriate time oh go ahead
let's let's wait what the committee
researcher has
yes
thank you very much Miss Grant so with
that clarification does the subcommittee
feel confident that we can continue to
have this discussion and
um kind of go forward how we feel uh
best as a committee and I know we work
so well together so
um I'll look to representative kongwa
who has been very helpful in this so
thank you
thank you madam chair so I mean I see
three options here
um going forward uh one we can recommend
the commission
two we can recommend a study committee
um
or three we cannot recommend anything at
all I think those are really the three
options that we sh uh
have in front of us regarding this based
on the testimony and everything that
we've heard last week and based on this
yes so
um looking at the difference between a
study commission and a study committee a
study committee is made up only of
legislators uh commission is made up of
legislators and other stakeholders and
uh one of the uh one of the arguments in
favor of a commission is that you have a
broader range of uh of stakeholders who
are actually at the table and it may
provide broader representation uh an
argument against a commission is that
the process of actually getting all
those stakeholders appointed by the
various people who are supposed to
appoint them can significantly delay the
uh the development of the study
commission the the study and uh it is
you can it is entirely within the power
of those stakeholders to attend every
session because it is a public hearing
and it is typically the practice of a
study committee to invite stakeholders
that they are aware of uh and uh and
it's specifically illicit test County
so just in terms of the smooth operation
there's I I have a preference towards a
study committee uh unless in in many in
there are there are some situations
where our study commission may be better
but in this particular situation I think
that in terms of getting the job done
efficiently uh a study committee would
be more effective okay thank you for
sharing that
for sharing that
Robert Bixby
um I'm going to look to representative
kongwa and then representative Stapleton
and then if representative homela has
thoughts we'll we'll do that as well
thank you madam chair and I'm going to
Echo
um representative bixby's uh
insight into study committee committee
versus a commission I serve on both
and I can tell you that in my personal
opinion a study committee can bring
everybody to the table it can take
it doesn't have to be done in one
meeting and we can enact and
promote legislation immediately a study
a commission
it takes years
literally and you're at the behest of
what the government is is asking for you
have to get permission to do some of the
things that we need to do
um working on the commission that I'm on
um and it's it's very
um slow moving
and if you really want to be proactive I
think the study committee is the way to
go
thank you representative control I'm
going to look to representative
Stapleton thank you madam chair um
I think the study committee is a both
timely and flexible
and I think that's important when we
have so much legislation so much work to
do and everybody's so busy we can be
more effective in an immediate basis
with a study a committee
and you know what one of the functions
of the study committee could be
ultimately if there's a great deal of
material and possibility that we
recommend a study commission another
bill going down the road so we haven't
cut that possibility off
um I was looking back at 111 and and the
Crux of it in in Roman 4 study the
commission study shall include but not
be limited to
uh examining the waste reduction goals
established in RSA 149 m
M and then B
um suggested legislation in order to
help update RSA 149 M to better meet the
waste reduction goals they're in you
know I think that focuses what we're all
about and I would have to read 149 M to
see how far it goes and how short it it
comes to meeting a goal and I apologize
for the to the study committee because I
missed the last meeting I had automobile
problems and have not had a chance to
really back up the homework on this
stuff so um I'm still trying to get my
head around it but I think this
discussion helps about which way to go
forward and study committee sounds like
a reasonable step to me thank you you're
welcome thanks for that Insight I would
also like to say that I do believe that
um
obviously we now have the solid waste
um plan that has been issued on October
1st and we have that as a compendium to
the the information that we would
potentially be considering before either
a commission or a committee so I think
that having that knowledge and that
information alongside of it is helpful
to addressing 149m which are our Solid
Waste sort of reduction
that's the vehicle for it through 149 M
so I would I would agree with you in
that statement and I would also say that
that report
um I think will be very helpful as well
as the work that we know is already
going on with the solid waste working
group that uh represented evil chairs
and had a discussion alongside of that
thank you
oh yes
thank you for a follow-up um two things
came to mind is there a deadline that we
have to deliver something on this study
committee that's a great question so yes
our recommendation needs to be ready to
go for next week to the Full House
environment and agriculture committee as
we will be meeting in an executive
session to take up all of the interim
study bills before us and what date is
that October 25th okay second question
is there an existing commission that
touches upon this subject at a greater
or lesser extent
thank you for the question so to some
degree there may be some conversation
within the solid waste working group
although they are two we are two
separate and different entities they
um there was some testimony last week
that they may take that up
um but at this point at when they had
testified before us there was not a they
had not Dove deeply into that area so
representative uh control might have a
recollection as well
thank you madam chairs so according to
the chair
um representative Ebel she of the solo
waste working group she said the epr is
way up on the study list
um and then she mentioned something
about HB 1167 which she uh when she
chaired that committee but she said that
representative Bixby oh sorry
representative Houma love first I had
recognized her for let's start thank you
um thank you very much I just wanted to
uh
to add to this that in the legislature
itself in the bill HB uh 111 it actually
lists both a committee and a commission
in the language just so you just so
we're aware of that and maybe that's
just a uh that's the way that OLS writes
things I'm not really sure but it says
in there
establish a committee to study extender
producer responsibility in the next line
in Roman 2 it says the members of the
commission shall
where are you seeing
so number line number one
um
and then Roman numeral two seems like it
it includes both of those it looks like
that might be a scrivener's error but I
the we have the prime sponsor of the
intend this to be a committee rather
excuse me I did write this bill as
commission I do believe that might have
been a typographical error however I
should also add in light of the
testimony that we heard most recently
I think a study uh committee would be a
fine way to proceed
uh that would seem to be the
recommendation of some of the people
that testified
and so I don't see that as being off
Target
follow up please you can follow up thank
you I just want to add this this third
perspective on to this
um everyone in this room agrees that
reduction of material and landfills is a
good thing so we're not having a
discussion necessarily about whether it
is a valid Noble goal or not that's
already a given
um we were talking about obviously the
study committee versus commission but I
I would add to that that it seems with
the solid waste working group and with
the
that it's their one of their on their
Radars one of their priorities and
within des and the fact that 13 state
legislatures are already Reinventing
this wheel or in the process of ending
this will I would actually counter that
even having a study committee we already
have the mechanisms in which to look at
this and if the solid waste working
group feels like this is one of their
largest priorities then get at it so I I
don't I'm not trying to throw shade on
any of that I'm just trying to say that
sometimes we bury ourselves in process
and I think the best goal is to be as
Nimble as possible and
if the solid waste working group can't
get this at get at this as a as a
reasonable
um
you know action item then there's no way
that our our agency structures are going
to be able to implement anything I mean
we just we have to move forward as we
can
and so I would actually recommend that
we actually have the structures in place
that could be looking at these and even
commission I think the it sounds like
from the room that a commission is maybe
not not something that might be
recommended this time but I would
actually sort of counter to that as well
that let's really look at whether
committee or not committee because I do
think that we have structures in place
through Des through the solid waste
working group that these conversations
can be had and and legislation can be
recommended thank you
uh thank you representative
representative Bixby right so one of the
one of the ways that a study committee
can work is to uh very Focus very
narrowly on what is needed for for
legislation and uh and if the if the if
this committee starts with the
understanding that legislation is
already you know or the assumption that
legislation is necessary and the
question is how do we craft that
legislation what needs to go into it
what do we need who do we need for
stakeholders then a study committee is
actually a better tool for getting the
specifics you need to put into the bill
than a broader work broader uh group
like the solid waste working group which
has the epr and it's as one of many
different uh priorities and we could
certain the study committee could
certainly work in constant in in concert
with uh the solid waste working group
but they would be able to uh delve more
deeply and more quickly into details
like uh how do we get the various
stakeholders on board with a particular
way of setting up the legislation so
um I think that a a study committee
would be a more effective way of
actually getting the legislation written
and uh
as opposed to looking at whether the
question is important
I from what I I hear what you're saying
is that if it's the assumption that
legislation is needed or legislation
needs to be moved forward but with
regard to Extended producer
responsibilities I'm not sure we fully
had that conversation of have we
you know does the house agree or not
agree that these costs should be passed
on to the manufacturers and is it their
responsibility we you know it's that
conversation that that cost will get
passed on to Consumers so I don't think
that's necessarily fleshed out that it's
a foregone conclusion that it's our
state's responsibility at this time to
I'm not saying that there it's not a
noble goal but we haven't I don't
believe fully had that conversation and
perhaps I'm mistaken uh representative
Pamela if I may speak to that and then
I'll I'll look to you one of the
um pieces of information that I do have
here that I do want to make sure that we
recognize is some background knowledge
on
um a report produced by The Ellen
MacArthur Foundation which looked at
over a hundred small medium and large
multinational industry uh Private
Industry stakeholders who signed onto
and they were very large from large
companies like the Pepsi Coca-Cola folks
to all sorts of other Industries
including uh Walmart was a signatory who
is really um they are looking at similar
and initiatives around this in the
private sector but they are also looking
to
um governments to help navigate some of
the challenges that there are with
needing to amend potentially some of the
legislative language to allow some of
these things to happen so in that in
that regard I do think to representative
bixby's point when we look at committee
versus commission the commission that we
know that is before is with the solid
wage working group is already looking at
a million different things there's a
large sort of
umbrella whereas a committee might
afford US the opportunity to be able to
look at things very narrowly
and when I chaired hb617
um and that was under the chairmanship
of representative O'Connor at that time
representative evil and Senator Waters
and myself that was looking at Solid
Waste and Recycling and we could that
was the very beginning of all of this
discussion in that sense where we really
dug our dug deep and had many meetings
where we were able to invite different
stakeholders to the table to give
testimony about a very very narrow areas
and I I imagine that we might be able to
achieve that with a recommendation of
that nature regarding just extended
producer responsibility I'm open to
hearing other thoughts
representative contract thank you madam
chair
um just in reading the the current bill
HB 1111
um the focus is on one particular RSA
which is 149 Dash m
and uh sitting on the study committee
that I am now where we're focusing on
one RSA I think it's very fruitful
because you can do a deep dive into an
RSA just to see what's going on and so
maybe uh instead of making this broad
because the solid working group is
already working on that broad thing
maybe we focus on RSA 149m
um to see you know and make that the
focus of this study committee I mean
because that way we're going through the
rsas we're making sure you can invite
everyone to the table and see if it is
indeed what we we wanted to say what it
says or if it needs to be updated or
changed and are we meeting the goals of
149-1 I think if we we could go from
that approach maybe a study committee
might be a viable option
representative Stapleton then
representative Homeland representative
Bixby
yes thank you madam chair of from my own
knowledge and edification here the
question to representative comp toy is
that the the commission that you're
working on that's the solid waste study
uh no I'm I'm on a study committee with
representative homiller and represent
Bixby and we're studying soil conditions
which is RSA 431.
okay
um follow up on my thoughts here
um
if if we have a study committee um
we can kind of learn as we go and that's
that's my case because I haven't got
enough experience or knowledge in the
matter to be a part of a commission so I
couldn't even get near that but a study
committee is is possible
um and and so once again I think that's
that's the only way that I could really
vote to go for the study committee
thank you uh representative komala
I I was just gonna add thank you I was
just going to add rep Contour you know
that that sounds like a a fourth way to
look at that I appreciate that thank you
representative Bixby right so
um there um I'd like to I think
that looking at
um a study committee that looks at
Fourth uh 149 and uh or what's is that
the right that's correct okay uh is
probably it would not actually be a
follow-up on the epr because
um epr is a very is I don't know that's
even mentioned in there uh 149 m is
basically the uh the chapter and statute
that covers all of solid waste stuff and
uh so
it would I think that would be that
would serve a different purpose
um and the question is whether or not we
want to
um look at
extended producer responsibility and how
we could uh enact that or also you know
if in the process of study we decide
that it doesn't make sense or uh whether
we want to study existing law and I that
might also be a good goal but I don't
think it's what should come out of this
uh this particular internal study thank
you representative Bixby if I may
interject for Jeff a moment I do think
that um the focus should be on the
concept of an extended producer
responsibility as it applies to 149 M
because 149 M May in fact require some
sort of amending we don't know to
include extended producer responsibility
in that concept and so to do so would
require a full committee studying
extended producer responsibility as it
just to answer that question so it is
almost certain that when whatever
legislation gets written about epr would
go into 149 now because that is that
would be this the appropriate section of
law but
um that's a different question from
whether we need to intensely study it uh
I understand what your your point is
thank you it's well taken representative
confla
thank you madam chair so just in reading
the bill
it says here the commissions based on
this it's the commission's study shall
include can you just tell us what line
you're on okay it is line 19.
and it says and then I go on to line 20
examining the waste reduction goals
established in 149 M then if you go to
23 suggested legislation in order to
help update RS 149 m
and it goes on and then it goes down
further I mean so really this commission
is all about 149 Dash m is what the
again University okay just one moment uh
yes representative homela I was just
gonna say that just in in reading that
it a case could be made that legislation
could be written that to look at 149
like you were saying with the expressed
interest of seeing how extended producer
responsibilities could be incorporated
into that RSA sort of it's almost like
you're taking out you're getting one
step ahead just by doing that
okay I can appreciate your perspective
uh representative Bixby did you have
just reread uh as representative pointed
out
um
I think that uh
I I could I I think that her Point makes
sense that it it does uh look at it
would be looking at the RSA 149m
particularly with yeah and looking at it
through a lens of potentially doing epr
but uh there there is a uh perhaps
figuring out what aspects of 149m would
work with that or not work with that and
might need to be changed
do it sounds like to me generally we
have an appetite for the concept of a
study committee are we at a place where
we could generally make a a a
recommendation
um
do we feel like we're at that place
as a subcommittee
we do okay so then I will look to
somebody to make a motion of a
recommendation
yes you can first before we do that
um just to clarify though
as we are making recommendations one way
or another
um I I feel more strongly about a study
committee focused under 149 with a
extended producer responsibility flavor
to that so I want to make sure that if
I'm affirming a study committee I'm not
affirming a generalized study committee
in which then we could put it in any box
later I just want to make sure we are
specifically talking about the type of
study committee sure I think the general
sense of what I am hearing from you all
is that we would like to look at
extended producer responsibility as it
applies to 149 m
is that what you are
okay
sure
representative Stapleton and
representative Contour
um are I would think we would have to
make a motion to make a recommendation I
think we have emotional version okay
thank you
thank you madam chair I make a motion
that the we recommend a study committee
to study RSA 149im with the focus on epr
do I have a second uh representative
all those in favor
aye
okay one two three four
oh one two three four five yes it's five
to zero it's unanimous the motion
carries
and with that uh we have 15 minutes left
over until I believe the next hearing is
scheduled so I will close out this
subcommittee work session I appreciate
for all of those who uh were joining
online and and to representative Davis
for attending as well thank you so much
and uh we look forward to seeing you in
the next legislature uh regarding 149
I'm an extended producer responsibility
foreign